So often we march like robots through our
broken educational system.
And if we continue like this, we may one day
have a robot as the President of the United
States.
Oh, you don't think it's possible?
Here's what his campaign would sound like.
[robotic voice] "I am R-Gen 1 and I am running
for President of the United States of America.
I am the most qualified candidate because
unlike humans, I have no emotions.
I make decisions based on pure logic, because
I have the most powerful processor in the
world.
I won't just make America great again.
I am great.
Vote for me R-Gen 1, the perfect president."
You can actually visualize it, can't you?
See for the longest time we've been so concerned
about robots taking over the world.
What most people don't realize is that it's
already happening.
We've become robots.
Our educational system is structured to turn
us into followers.
You see, what separates us from robots is
the fact that we have the ability to question
things.
But we've stopped using that ability.
Think about it this way.
How is it that colleges are selling textbooks
for $200 to 18-year-old kids when it only
costs $6 to make?
Why is it that tuition costs as much as it
does?
And why is it that we're pressuring parents
to use their retirement savings to pay for
their kids' college education?
Does this make any sense to you?
This is why I believe this is the perfect
time for us to question our educational system
before it's too late.
On January 24th Patrick Bet-David will launch
"Dropout and Get Schooled."
And you'll see how one book will disrupt the
entire educational system.